president trump live on the on tape
rather on the south lawn telling
reporters he'll name his supreme court
nominee
5 p.m saturday let's listen in having a
conference
[Music]
i've talked to many people many people
okay why haven't you said anything about
the us hitting 200
000 go ahead uh anybody else
[Music]
thanks for milestone today
to the virus what do you want to say to
the american people well i think it's a
shame
i think if we didn't do it properly and
do it right
you'd have two and a half million deaths
if you take a look at uh
alternatives you could have two and a
half million deaths
or something they're about you could
have a number that would be
substantially more with all of that
being said we shouldn't have had anybody
and you saw my united nations speech
china should have stopped it at their
border
they should have never let this spread
all over the world
and it's a terrible thing but had we not
closed our country down
and reopened and now we're doing well in
reopening the stock market's up
all of those things but i think it's a
horrible thing
but if we'd not if we had not done it
right you could have two million
two and a half million or three million
but it's a horrible thing
should have never ever happened china
let this happen
and just remember that
well i know this the original numbers
were
around 200 000 if you do it right if you
did a
good job and if the public worked along
and uh
and if you didn't do it right you'd be
at two million two and a half million
those were the numbers but uh this
should have never happened
they should have never come out of china
they should have never let it happen
so that's it
well i don't want to talk about who i'm
meeting with but i've spoken to many
and we're getting close to a decision
we're going to be doing it on
saturday we're going to be meeting on
saturday
lot of paperwork to do and i think it's
going to go very quickly
[Music]
oh i don't think so i we need nine
justices
you need that uh with the
unsolicited millions of ballots that
they're sending it's a scam it's a hoax
everybody knows that
and the democrats know it better than
anybody else so you're going to need
nine justices up there i think it's
going to be very important
because what they're doing is a hoax
with the ballots
they're sending out tens of millions of
ballots
unsolicited not where they're being
asked but unsolicited
and that's a hoax and you're going to
need to have nine justices so
doing it before the election would be a
very good thing
because you're going to probably see it
because what they're doing is trying to
sow confusion and everything else
and you know when they talk about russia
china and all these
others they will be able to do something
here
because paper ballots are very simple
whether they counterfeit them
forge them do whatever you want it's a
very serious problem
and the democrats know what they're
doing is wrong
and all they want to do is go forward
with it so
i think you're going to need the nine
justices
also i have a constitutional obligation
to put in nine judges so justices so
uh i think you're going to be very
impressed
when you see all of them i mean they're
all great these are all very talented
people
and i think you'll be very impressed by
the person chosen